avant que la vidéo commence sachez qu'un
nouveau concours in stone gaming est
lancé pour participer c'est très simple
il vous suffit d'accéder aux liens du
concours disponibles dans la description
et de rentrer le nom du jeu que vous
aimeriez avoir et c'est tout bonne
chance à tous nous sommes environ un an
et demi après la sortie de star wars 9
les fans ont été divisés les réactions
étaient très fortes
mais je vous avoue que moi ben a sonné
loin j'aimerais bien vous reparler de la
saga aujourd'hui et notamment me
concentrer sur rai qui est et restera
pour moi le personnage avec le plus de
potentiel dans cette nouvelle trilogie
on n'oublie pas évidemment key lorraine
et on lui passe le bonjour ainsi nous
regarde
mais pour de vrai l'histoire de ray au
final commence tout juste
avec la fin de rise of skywalker
abandonné sur jack ou dès son plus jeune
âge rae a beaucoup souffert du manque de
ses parents de ne pas connaître ses
origines ne pas savoir d'où elle vient
une thématique plutôt approprié pour
star wars qui est une grande histoire de
famille en quelque sorte surtout la saga
principale son abandon était au final
une protection contre dark sidious car
étant la petite fille est digne
héritière des palpatine l'empereur
souhaitait avoir une descendance dans le
but d'avoir à disposition un corps
capable de contenir ces immenses
pouvoirs
le père étant considéré comme une
expérience de clonage raté puisqu'il
n'avait aucun lien avec la force une
palpatine malgré tout rêve a trouvé
refuge dans le nom des skywalker
notamment grâce au soutien de l'eia et
l'enseignement de l'udc qui ont eu
l'image et l'effet de parents adoptifs
pour cette dernière
mais la plus grosse prise de conscience
a été sa relation avec cai lorraine lié
à ben solo à cause de la prophétie de la
dyade dans la force
rae a pu comprendre et apprendre
énormément de choses grâce à l'histoire
profonde de ben qui baigne dans la force
depuis son plus jeune âge notamment à
cause d'un héritage lourd étant le
petit-fils d'anakin et car il a été
formé à la fois par l'udc
puis parce nok soit le côté lumineux et
le côté obscur et le fait d'avoir été
très proche de luke leia appui qui
lorraine lors de son come back
cela a clairement orienté rey à devenir
une nouvelle personne qui a sa propre
vision de la force
là où l'udc souhaitait la fin des jedi
ray lui a prouvé que ce n'était pas
nécessaire
là où key lawrence où étais tu es le
passé donc à la fois les jedi et les
sith les adeptes du côté obscur ray lui
a prouvé qu'il faut savoir se servir du
passé pour mieux amener l'avenir
et c'est là pour moi les deux points
importants qui symboliserait aujourd'hui
et pour son futur via cette scène de fin
ray nous montre que oui il faut savoir
tourner la page comme le montre le
moment où elle enterre les sabres laser
de luke et leia mais qu'il faut
également se souvenir pour mieux rebâtir
skywalker est un nom inspirant liés aux
plus grandes légendes et à l'histoire de
la galaxie est là où elle n'est pas le
patine puis est devenu personne suite
aux choix et aux actes de ses parents
elle choisi de perpétuer l'héritage
skywalker non pas comme un simple
hommage à luc où les gars ou même encore
ben mais comme la reprise de ce qu'ils
ont échoué à faire avec une nouvelle
vision et de nouvelles bases saines
mais bon ça reste ma vision personnelle
évidemment tout cela reste subjectif est
propre à chacun maintenant si nous
voulons faire comme ray et bâtir un
nouvel avenir prometteur nous devons
nous tourner vers l'état d'esprit de
disney et lucasfilm la nouvelle trilogie
a été teasé comme la fin de l'histoire
des skywalker et c'est quelque chose qui
m'est toujours resté en tête mais des
fois je me demande si cette trilogie n'a
pas existé seulement pour relancer la
hype star wars éteinte depuis la
prélogie est à la fois tourné la page
concernant les personnages de muc and ou
encore les ya par exemple
encore une fois cette idée d'enterrer le
passé pour redéfinir l'avenir soit
terminée les vieilles histoires et
tourner la page pour proposer du neuf
basé sur l'ancien est ce que vous voyez
ce que je veux dire
concernant leur vision et au vu des
dernières déclarations d'oeuvre les
films ne semble plus être une priorité
le petit écran est privilégiée c'est
l'arrivée des séries pour l'univers star
wars
donc je le call comme ça mais la
possibilité de revoir
et un jour dans une petite série disney
plus ça ne me paraît pas si improbable
que ça surtout que désire hadley
l'actrice de rennes est pas fermée pour
reprendre le rôle un jour sans oublier
évidemment que star wars et ce n'est pas
faute de le rappeler est une saga non
chronologique c'est une saga semblable à
un texte à trous qui a besoin d'être
comblé comme rogue wave qui comble un
trous scénaristiques de l'opus quatre
mandats lauriane qui comble le trou
entre stars war 6 et 7 et cetera et
cetera
mais du coup on tourne beaucoup autour
du pot on mais vachement de contexte
mais au final qu'attendons-nous du futur
de ré après star wars neuf et bien déjà
par rapport au fait de tourner la page
sur l'histoire de la trilogie et
s'inspirer du passé pour un nouvel
avenir
nous avons la présence des anciens
textes de jedi qui servent aujourd'hui
de base référente pour ré dont le culte
jedi
ce n'est pas forcément bien expliqué
dans le film ou montrer mais ray en
volant les livres nous a prouvé qu'elle
a énormément appris sur la force grâce à
ça et cela va clairement continue on
parle de siècle et deux millénaires
d'histoire est de savoir dans ses textes
il y a un peu un délire de necronomicon
un livre provenant de lovecraft
traduisant l'idée d'un artefact
réunissant tout le savoir magique entre
guillemets sans oublier également les
fantômes de la force
ray est peut-être la dernière j'ai
taillé vivantes les personnages comme
l'udc ou bien yoda ont prouvé à maintes
reprise qu'il pouvait encore agir et
aiguiller pour aider ray dans son
parcours
c'est également le cas pour ben qui lui
dit clairement qu'il ne la laissera
jamais tout seul il restera toujours à
ses côtés
via la force donc une multitude de
moyens pour ré de s'informer de
comprendre d'apprendre pour adapter son
rôle de
dernière des jedi de plus grâce aux
livres rêve pouvoir étudier la manière
originel du rôle des jedi dans la
galaxie et donc pourquoi pas s'en
inspirer
je pense bien évidemment à tout le côté
protection des autres la tranquillité
intérieure ou encore la transmission de
savoirs à la transmission de savoirs
juste le cas de fines en est le parfait
exemple lui qui ressent la force et qui
souhaitait en parler arrêt il a
maintenant tout le temps de le faire et
d'apprendre de sa bff tout comme le
groupe d'ex stormtrooper dirigé par john
a
c'est une pseudo théorie plutôt
populaire medjana nous confirme
clairement qu'elle et ses alliés ont eu
un instinct un sentiment de devoir
quitter le premier ordre et se rebeller
des signaux montrant qu'ils sont
sensibles à la force comme fille n'avait
pu le faire dans star wars 7
sans oublier les symboles que
représentent certains comme des mairies
blague un enfant esclave capable de
manipuler la force
et si c'était ça justement la mission de
ré aujourd'hui la nouvelle trilogie nous
l'a montré il peut exister des
utilisateurs neutre de la force ou des
êtres sensibles
mais sauront-ils exploiter tout le
potentiel de cette dernière est dans la
bonne direction car c'est quelque chose
que je crois personnellement mais même
si le culte site a disparu dans star
wars 9 la colère et la haine peuvent
mener dans la mauvaise direction
alors et cirés à la manière de charles
xavier avec les jeunes mutants
chercherait les êtres sensibles à la
force à travers la galaxie pour les
guider et les aider justement bon ok
j'avoue je pars un petit peu loin mais
en vrai ça colle parfaitement d'ailleurs
dans le but de parfaire son savoir et sa
maîtrise ray pourrait également partir à
la recherche d'anciens temple jedi
pourquoi pas mais qui l'amènerait
justement à de nouvelles rencontres
car oui s'il y a bien une question qui
m'intrigue avec le futur de ré c'est sa
rencontre avec d'autres utilisateurs de
la force mais des utilisateurs prononcer
nous ne savons pas réellement si ahsoka
est morte pendant le moment où rey
appelle tous les jedi à lui venir en
aide
pourtant sa voix est là david filo ni
une figure majeure du développement de
la saga nous dit qu'il est possible que
cette dernière ne soit pas décédé durant
star wars 9 mai ne l'affirment pas non
plus il ne l'a pas crier sur tous les
toits donc voilà c'est possible que ray
et ahsoka se rencontrent un jour mais le
plus intéressant pour moi et gros goût
tout simplement car gros bout et
destinés à vivre longtemps
si tout se passe bien il a connu l'ordre
jedi de l'époque et surtout il a été
pris sous les ailes de l'udc pour
apprendre la force
l'udc dont l'académie jedi a été
détruite par cas et lorraine et qui
n'est plus accompagné par gros goût
quand il est sur actes aux dons qui sait
où il se trouve
au moment de star wars 9 étant donné que
le broco a été placé sous la garde de
l'udc et que la passation de rôle a été
effectuée de l'udc arrêt il existe un
moyen de lier
2 et c'est là en fait pour moi l'intérêt
de continuer l'histoire de ray après le
9 qui est loin d'être la fin de son
histoire personnelle
tout concorde par rapport à sa vision et
ses objectifs réels entité qui doit nous
faire parcourir le poste star wars 9
elle est la dernière entité importante
de la saga à ce moment précis
sachez en tout cas que cette vidéo
traduit simplement ma vision personnelle
du sujet cela faisait un petit temps que
nous n'avions pas parler de star wars et
je suis satisfait de l'avoir fait
aujourd'hui évidemment une multitude de
possibilités existent quant à l'avenir
de ré peut-être que nous ne reverrons
jamais le personnage à l'écran
peut-être que si a vous de me dire votre
avis sur la question dans l'espace
commentaires comme toujours j'ai très
hâte de vous lire et puis ici la vidéo
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à laisser un
petit pouce bleu ou à vous abonner ou
bien les deux tout simplement c'est très
bien aussi que le lionheart soit avec
vous n'oubliez pas le petit concours un
stand gaming c'était argot rock
allez ciao tout
[Musique]